encore un café quand on est maman de
famille nombreuse le café c'est la vie
c'est mon carburateur
[Musique]
mon carburant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à l'heure
des pros ce matin c'est au choix
classique ou un scandale une habitude ou
une honte c'est la grève de la SNCF en
décembre qui arrive en même temps que
les vacances de Noël
vous nous avez tous dit que vous en
aviez ras-le-bol
combien vous avez gagné d'étoiles 4 il
faut en laisser pour les camarades
travailleurs vous avez pas le monopole
du coeur
comme l'année dernière et comme l'année
prochaine une menace plane sur vos
vacances de Noël cette fois-ci les
contrôleurs réclaunes de salaire de 200
euros si j'ai bien compris l'année 2022
Furude covid essence électricité
incendie inflation pénurie etc avec
l'aide SNCF on n'est jamais déçu on m'en
veut tellement que je suis obligé de me
justifier de rencontrer l'épreuve en
fait je sais que Nicolas me comprenne je
sais que c'est du rein c'est normal
ce qui perd sa femme j'ai un cœur quand
même mais après je comprends qu'il soit
dégoûté je comprends qu'il soit triste
mais c'est
le jeu
c'est toujours embêtant d'être pris en
otage pour Noël parce que ça arrive
régulièrement et c'est vrai que c'est
fatiguant tous les ans à la même période
ils font grève et clairement ils nous
emmerdent est-ce que leurs conditions de
travail justifie à tel point de faire
grève je sais pas mes chers je vous
annonce une augmentation du Smic à 2500
euros par mois surtout pour les familles
nombreuses car ils en ont besoin
constater on est un peu dans le noir
puisque les économies ont commencé les
bougies et les coupures de courant sont
annoncés donc nous avons prévu quelques
petites bougies j'ai écouté madame borne
tout va bien en France en 2022 c'est ici
dans cette salle de contrôle à l'adresse
tenue secrète que des opérateurs
couperont l'électricité si besoin cet
hiver les fameux délestages bonjour
Sébastien Sarrazin qui va vous donner
l'ordre de couper l'électricité certes
qui nous l'enverra les coupures qui
dureront deux heures par jour au maximum
lors des pics de consommation entre 8
heures et 13h ou entre 18h et 20h aucun
département ne sera entièrement privé de
courant ce sera par zone jamais la même
zone ne sera délesté deux fois de suite
on va commencer par couper une partie
des clients c'est à dire que là on voit
qu'il y a une ligne électrique qui est
coupée avec l'ensemble des clients de
ceux qui sont coupés ça va durer deux
heures après ces deux heures en fait on
va à la fois rétablir les clients et à
la fois couper une logique électrique
donc là on voit cette ligne qui est
coupée et puis quand on arrive à la fin
du délai ça et ben en fait c'est terminé
l'ensemble des clients soit
en avant le pouvoir oh là là mais là
vous êtes dans le noir là qu'est-ce qui
se passe l'électricité vous avez pu
d'électricité
en contre-jour franchement Jacques vous
faites de la télé puis 50 ans c'est vrai
que c'est un peu embêtant et ça nous
contraint à faire peut-être
la cuisine à d'autres moments sans
électricité c'est compliqué surtout pour
le télétravail en fait c'est repenser un
peu son organisation
en termes de lessive ou de choses comme
ça et bon c'est vrai que ce matin j'ai
mis une machine en route dans une
dizaine d'établissements du sud du pays
garçon et fille ont abandonné leur
uniforme genre
pour plus de parité
désormais c'est pantalons pour tous et
vous savez que ça c'est drôle ce que
vous dites parce que les femmes de
Pharaon étaient enterrés avec leur mari
je peux dire qu'elle s'occupait bien de
leur mari parce que le jour il est passé
elle est avec ce soir l'équipe de France
de football ne joue pas au Qatar elle se
prépare pour son match de 8e de finale
face à la Pologne dimanche mais une
française est sur le terrain l'arbitre
Stéphanie frappard à 38 ans elle est la
première femme à arbitrer un match de
Coupe du Monde masculine à ses débuts en
Ligue 2 un entraîneur de Valenciennes
lui avait reproché de ne pas avoir
sifflé un penalty en disant elle n'a
rien vu peut-être qu'elle faisait du
patinage c'est compliqué pour une femme
d'arbitré un sport d'homme et ses propos
sexistes avaient valu deux matchs de
suspension à l'entraîneur macho avant
avec une jupe c'était beaucoup plus
difficile pour moi de grimper ici
maintenant je peux le faire et j'adore
ça
on peut faire exactement les mêmes jeux
que les garçons on joue même au foot
ensemble maintenant lors d'un forum à
Bruxelles consacré aux investissements
pour la ville de Kiev la mère de Paris
Anne Hidalgo s'est permis de donner un
conseil à Vladimir kitchco le frère du
maire de la capitale ukrainienne pour
reconstruire sa ville
vous devez avoir un plan si vous
souhaitez reconstruire
pour transformer les infrastructures
urbaines
et passer de la voiture au vélo
alors vous m'avez fait la sorcière vous
faire la promotion du vélo à un pays en
guerre une honte pour de nombreux
internautes français d'autres en
rouleront préférés s'amuser avec
notamment des arrêts sur image de
clitschko au bord de mes lèvres très
bien
alors justement c'est le problème
et ben alors Pascal il fallait nous
mettre un mot de plus là
malgré tout ces préliminaires ça ne
rentre toujours pas
au rayon gênance difficile de faire
mieux